one reason many of us think of Christmas
as the most wonderful time of the year
is the fun of getting and giving gifts
to friends and family as Winston
Churchill observed we make a living by
what we get but we make a Life by what
we give on that theme Barry Peterson
found a woman in Denver who makes
holiday giving a delicious treat so I'm
hand dipping
the caramel apples in a milk chocolate
and then I'm putting them in almonds and
toffee all Meek and fonte has is a
kitchen caramel's almost ready and an
idea making as many as 2 000 caramel
apples a year I'm a big cook that sell
for all of 10 bucks each on a busy day
about two to three hundred and raising
ten to twenty thousand dollars a year
that she's donated to schools libraries
a hospice I've got my one job that's for
sure husband Rob an oculofacial plastic
surgeon pays for the supplies and pushes
in those wooden sticks I'm lucky to have
a wife who's got such a great idea
childhood friend Kelly Fox is a
paralympic silver Medal winner and when
it comes to raising money Kelly and
Megan didn't stop with apples riding
together in bicycle races that raised
fifty thousand dollars I gave a friend
an apple and she just held it in her
hand and just started doing a dance she
was like oh my gosh this is for me
it brings Joy it really started with
Megan's mom Marie who raised 10 kids
started a hospice and ran a food bank
out of her garage I would ask her could
I go down the street and play at Peggy's
house and she'd say I need you to bag 50
pounds of rice and 50 pounds of beans
and one pound bags and then you can go
play so we all did it we all did it back
in those days Susan Schmitz was a
childhood friend who knows now why
demand keeps growing basically Word of
Mouth you know everybody receives them
as a present then they want to buy them
next year for their friends and family
and this year the apples will help with
an Innovative cause so this land is
where we're going to build our community
it's where we're going to build Tall
Tales Ranch Susan Mooney founded Tall
Tales Ranch that will provide housing
for adults with intellectual and
developmental differences this is a
population of people who want to work
who want to live independently who are
going to have to move out of their
parent house at some point because their
parents are aging like her son Ross who
may one day live here and the apples
help the apples helped tremendously not
only have they helped us raise funds but
they help us raise awareness
back in the kitchen it's my turn as a
taste tester chocolate
sprinkles almonds
very tart apple mm-hmm
lovely caramel and here's one more
dubious selling point we don't count
calories there's no calories in an apple
when you do it for charity I think the
point is is that anybody does anything
good we can do it in our own backyard
put a little white chocolate on it all
it takes and then we decorate with some
fall leaves is just doing it that's good
for CBS Saturday morning Barry Peterson
Denver
it's a great point if you're eating for
charity at the calories no calories
don't count I'll have two I like that
Berry was a taste tester instead of like
trying to make them I thought that was a
very wise way to go what a great idea
though a simple doable thing that makes
a real impact we're talking ten twenty
thousand dollars yeah A Difference Maker
and a mini dish yeah